okay future career as a TV host over  here or two guys think music you think  she flew in your steps what are you  hoping well semana Jagger and I have  quite the Elison on a Dan so we're  excited you guys I have to ask you your  tour is right around the corner are you  all prepped and ready how's that going  we've been in rehearsal actually Jagger  was at a rehearsal today really dancing  it up so we have the best background  dancer ever today we bring in the family  on the road how's that how's it gonna be  you love it don't you  now what we're gonna family on the road  what are the holiday plans for the  family we're going to Greenwich to be  with my mom  this is my favorite interview I've ever  done low and say your name Ross  [Music]  [Applause]